my current plans for this Saturday night
are exactly like my ability to
understand how to fix the smoke
detectors in my house I don't have any
no I'm a Miss Korea no no your no your
life is different now welcome to another
cooking video with me and hellofresh
brand never fuses to stop supporting me
even when I really prove consistently
that I can't be trusted or like that
parent that has the kids they put in
like dance classes when they're younger
and like the kid should not do dance but
they're like give it time I've been
having a full me Saturday I've been
watching making a murderer to for eight
hours today yeah I might be making
myself a murderer of my time and ability
to like do anything productive however I
did exercise and now I'm starving
so all of this works out perfectly I'm
going to make a meal be a hell of a
fresh because I feel like this might
give me the false sense of I did
something today let's get into some
talking points cuz this is very clearly
a branch of sponsored video I'm not
gonna hide that from you like I'm not
gonna hide the fact that I've had some
vodka before this videos that seem cool
investing here we go
aloe fresh is basically a subscription
box service that sends you pre-measured
meals with these easy-to-follow
recipe cards that give you six steps
with six visuals that you have seen me
in the past fail at so we'll see what
happens today
that was some hummus look I had that's
not like a phrase had hummus before I
started shooting this video but that
could be a very fun new phrase right get
it internetting that was some hummus
like that was a little stanky but hello
fresh you can spend last time meal
planning and grocery shopping and more
time doing what you love like shooting
videos on Saturday night using aloe
fresh each their own to eat Shirley's
thorough and today we're going back to
one of their classic meals we're doing
bulgogi bowl see bulgogi bowls is how
you say that
hold on you know Benny everyone listen
up together go go go go go go yeah that
seems not correct we're gonna make some
people to judge poll we're gonna make a
beef okay
Oh as always everything for your meal
with hellofresh comes in Miss Perfect
please pack it's a little adult lunch
sack other than like the meat which mean
does anyone need to pee does anyone need
a drink
what do you guys need is everyone okay
why a vegetable let's start making this
beef okay
bull oh this is white my vinaigrette
literally I thought this was like an
airplane bottle like always the built-in
drinking game is guess which step you
think I'm gonna severely shop and then
you know reward yourself cook rice cook
rice and prep I forget at the start of
cooking sucks
wash and dry all the produce mother I
always hate this part and I always hold
on to the idea that maybe it's not the
first step yeah just wash it just wash
it in a small pot combine rice 3/4 cup
of water and a pinch of salt into a boil
then cover and reduce heat to low I
immediately forgot what the instructions
were pinch of salt
you got pinch meanwhile trim and thinly
slice this gallon it's already begun
trim and thinly sliced scallions
separating whites from green onions are
these fun little flailing friends are
they a vegetable everything is a
vegetable it's not a bread or a me oh
you guys look scraggly you look like the
ends of my hair this is like a witch
hand she's like been super dehydrated
nice wrestlemania shirt ain't gonna beef
bulgogi oh how am I not the next
Bachelorette hasn't been a very strong
relationship cut off these weird little
hairy oldest those are two terrible
adjectives chop them up separate the
jacks and whites from the Hank and John
Green how you guys who'd you [ __ ] sober
this week now we've moved on to step two
which means where did it go cheers to
number twos I'm immature and I love that
about me next we're gonna
pickle a cucumber that sounds so in a
medium bowl no offense that you seem
very medium we're going to combine
vinegar half a teaspoon of sugar shoot I
don't have regular sugar it's only half
a teaspoon so that's a very tiny amount
so I'm gonna put half a teaspoon of
Splenda in there don't at me sugar and
then we're gonna add a pinch of salt
whoo you get pinched again okay then
using a peeler we're gonna shave the
cucumber lengthwise that's what he said
well here we go
it smells weird why do they let me do
these videos just shave in the cucumber
on a Saturday night pic I'm alone go
ahead tweet me your worst gifs of this
hey that's enough and we toss it in this
vinegar mixture and then we set it aside
to pickle what a tease we've finished
step two on to step three I'm very
confident we are going to heat a drizzle
of oil and a large preferably nonstick
pan or medium-high heat we're gonna add
carrots cook stirring just until tender
and season with salt and pepper turn off
the heat and transfer to a plate oh I
killed a bug with my bare hand
what who texted me curious if anyone has
experience or looked into installing bar
boxes to encourage fats in the
neighborhood to help combat more
I gotta go cook some carrots carrots
Evan puts it aside now we're on to step
four time to cook the beef we're gonna
heat another drizzle of olive oil in the
same pan then we're gonna add the
scallion whites and cook until fragrant
about 30 seconds and we're gonna add the
beef and a pinch of salt and pepper and
I'm gonna cook breaking the meat to
pieces until browned thoroughly for
about five to seven minutes rice is done
I've also been watching pose Oh No oh
shoot I was only supposed to put half
the vinegar in the pickling of the
cucumber I don't supposed about half of
it in with the beef after it's brown so
gradual ations to all of you to guess
and you nailed it cheers to you I'll be
classy and use a glass oh we're gonna
keep cooking the beef for like another a
couple minutes until it's brown through
then we're gonna add half the sesame
seed path and the remaining vinegar
which I think I'm gonna pour in rum this
bowl beef is basically done so we're
gonna add half of our sesame seeds and
the remaining vinegar we cook that for
30 seconds and then we stir in bulgogi
sauce this unlabeled package of curious
brown liquid I assume is the bulgogi
sauce and then we bring to a simmer and
once it's simmering then we turn the
heat off and we season again with salt
pepper next step now we're gonna make
some sriracha crema
crema cramp cream we're gonna make a
spicy sauce that's gonna give me the
[ __ ]
cute so we take a small ball we combine
some sour cream and sriracha and some
water until the mixture reaches a
drizzling consistency yeah I love to put
things in my body that when they come
out of their packaging already look like
they're coming out of my thought hole
seems cool oh that seems like that's a
very slow drizzle I'll take it oh so we
de flopped the rice with the pork and
stir in a tablespoon of butter and
season with salt and pepper okay I'm
gonna put this dish together and it's
gonna be real cool
oh okay it's time for our food reveal
party ready oh my gosh oh my gosh I mean
she's pretty close this is her arriving
at the bar for her tender day this is
her after like the three Smirnoff shots
that she took in her apartment before
the tinder date kick in final talking
points and with all hellofresh sponsored
videos on this channel you guys can sign
up I go into hellofresh comm and you can
get eight free meals or eighty dollars
off your first month I've used the promo
code grace helbig 80 again go to
hellofresh comm use the promo code grace
Helbig 84 $80 off eight females on your
first month how about fresh is now some
six dollars and then cents per serving
and I will prove just how delicious this
is let's get a little bit of very for it
yep you chew your cool I'm out it's
great it tastes delicious I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did give
it a thumbs up turn on the bail
notifications or I don't know what's
happening on this platform as you all
know at this point I press videos other
than that
don't forget the memory card and I our
podcast this might get weird is going on
tour go into seven cities all the links
for tickets are in the description box
below so please check that out we cannot
wait to see you around the u.s. sorry if
we're not going to a place that you live
in this is just the start hope and my
camera cut me off which means that I
should go so other than that I don't
know this is me being a travel blogger
this is my camping travel blogger
because I go from my bedroom to my
kitchen and then to a bathroom